et on va plus loin avec un madame
mustaphavi directrice adjointe de
L'Express bonjour à Madame on va voir la
Une de L'Express que vous nous avez
apportée cette semaine et que l'on va
jouer dans un instant la Une de
L'Express ils ont cassé EDF état
dirigeant Bruxelles évidemment l'Union
européenne c'est évidemment l'état des
réacteurs nucléaires du parc nucléaire
français aujourd'hui tout à fait on a
aussi un dossier sur l'Iran puisque vous
savez qu'il y a des manifestations
importantes et on parle bien sûr de la
guerre et de la en
Ukraine et on va en parler bien sûr
aujourd'hui avec également Bruno Darroux
chroniqueur international
merci d'être avec nous Bruno il n'entend
pas lui un perte de temps visiblement
Vladimir Poutine sitôt conclut les
parodies de référendum organisés sous la
menace russe dans plusieurs régions
d'Ukraine qu'il convoitent le maître du
Kremlin reconnaîtra dès demain vendredi
l'annexion de ces quatre territoires à
la Fédération de Russie écouter de Mitry
pescov le porte-parole de la présidence
russe
la sécurité des personnes
voilà la ligne rouge de la République
islamique d'Iran
n'est autorisé
le président a peut-être pouvoir
entendre Mitry escort j'attends la
confirmation
visiblement on n'a pas la possibilité
d'entendre me tripes on annonce donc je
vous le disais également un grand
concert géant à Moscou et voilà où on
est la situation on en rajoute dans le
triomphalisme Bruno ah bah en tout cas
le Kremlin et Vladimir Poutine vont
vouloir montrer que c'est un grand jour
un jour de célébration alors sur
peut-être d'ailleurs on verra les images
demain enfin ce qui aura peut-être un
côté un peu bon peut-être pas un dessin
quoi que un peu déplacé comparé aux
souffrances et aux morts d'ailleurs que
qui concerne aussi les soldats russes
sur le terrain mais effectivement
Vladimir Poutine qui est dans une
position difficile son armée est sur la
en Ukraine donc c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
qu'il a lancé toutes ces annexions et
qu'il les valide à toute allure parce
qu'il y avait plusieurs scénarios pour
la validation en termes de calendrier
visiblement on choisit le calendrier le
plus rapide 48 heures à peine ce qui
traduit d'ailleurs une certaine
fébrilité bref Vladimir Poutine a besoin
de montrer à sa population ça c'est
plutôt un objectif de politique interne
que ça y est après 7 mois de guerre il y
a quand même ce premier résultat c'est
concret 15 à 20% du territoire ukrainien
qui tombe aux mains de la Russie qui
rejoint voilà la mère patrie en quelque
sorte évidemment ils vont en faire un
peu des tonnes si vous me passez
l'expression on annonce un discours très
très long parce que en fait il l'est
quand même dans une position délicate et
il a besoin absolument d'affirmer que
cette guerre sert à quelque chose et
surtout qu'elle finit par produire des
résultats en faveur de la Russie une
fois ces territoires proclamésus quelle
est d'après vous l'étape suivante madame
à l'étape suivante c'est pas tellement
c'est pas seulement un Poutine de la
décider c'est un peu à nous tous parce
que ce qui est sûr c'est que Poutine il
sait qu'il ne peut pas gagner la guerre
il sait qu'ils n'ont pas la gagner
réellement en tout cas il va pas a
priori maîtrise du territoire
totale du territoire ukrainien mais en
tout cas il va refuser jusqu'au bout de
reconnaître qu'il peut perdre qu'il a
perdu en fait et du coup qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire que si
l'Ukraine ou les pays occidentaux ne
reconnaissent pas sa politique du fait
accompli puisque c'est bien ça de ça
qu'il s'agit ici
tout peut se produire c'est un prétexte
pour intensifier la guerre parce que
annexer des territoires qu'il ne peut
pas de fait administrer aujourd'hui
c'est précipiter de nouvelles violences
ou un engrenage oui alors ce qu'on ne
sait pas alors d'abord effectivement il
faut rappeler que les quatre territoires
annexés à la Russie ne sont pas
entièrement sous le contrôle des troupes
russes et non seulement ne sont pas sous
le contrôle des troupes totalement mais
même encore aujourd'hui l'armée
ukrainienne a progressé autour de la
ville assez stratégiques de l'imam donc
absolument donc les Ukrainiens en fait
viennent tout récemment finalement de
réoccuper une partie de cette aubelaste
alors même qu'il proclame le
rattachement à la Russie on voit bien
d'ailleurs que la stratégie des
Ukrainiens c'est surtout pas de
négociation en ce moment puisque la
dynamique est de leur côté Dimitri
pescov celui qu'on n'a pas pu écouter
d'ailleurs lui a à fait resurgir cette
idée de de négociation côté russe
[Musique]
explique en ce moment sur le sur le
terrain après la question c'est est-ce
que la diplomatie derrière va vraiment
faire le suivre ce chemin parce qu'à
partir du moment où Poutine déclare ce
sont des territoires russes bon on sait
que les conditions de l'affrontement ou
d'une intensification d'une
intensification écrit aussi les
conditions pour que les pays occidentaux
à un moment donné interrogent le
président zenki et lui dise attention
aussi parce que même si évidemment
l'Occident soutien énormément l'Ukraine
quand il arrive à un moment de tension
extrême on sait que Poutine a fait
beaucoup de fois références à l'arme
nucléaire personne ne pensait
heureusement qu'il peut utiliser mais il
y a un an personne ne pensait qu'il
allait envahir l'Ukraine donc on est
face à un personnage qui a 70 ans dans
quelques jours c'est bientôt son
anniversaire je ne je franchement je
m'engage rien voilà je doute de rien
donc je pense qu'on ne sait pas et que
il est possible que à partir du moment
il déclare l'annexion ce sont des
territoires russes pour lui si ces
territoires ressources agressés il peut
riposter de toute manière
parce que je pense en fait pour le
moment il y a eu un petit mouvement du
côté occidental ou effectivement un
moment je disais bon bah tiens s'il
récupère le sud et l'est ça sera
peut-être le moment de négocier de figer
un peu les positions etc mais
aujourd'hui vu effectivement les succès
de l'armée ukrainienne Anthony blinken
est encore quelques heures à 10 qu'il
est en train de faire c'est pas une
annexion tout simplement c'est de la
saisie de terre donc c'est absolument
illégal Antonio goûter reste lui-même a
été assez dur c'est-à-dire c'est une
violation de la Charte de l'ONU que
d'annexer des territoires qui
appartiennent à un autre pays même la
Chine ne soutient pas Anthony
utérusen ils ont une caractéristique
c'est qu'ils sont à des milliers de
kilomètres de ce qui se passe donc ce
que je veux dire c'est que ils n'ont pas
les Américains
mais c'est vrai que c'est vrai que quand
même
j'attends de voir moi ce qui se passe
une fois que que Poutine a des carrés
que ce sont des territoires c'est très
compliqué parce que l'Ukraine elle-même
qui est quand même le principal acteur
sur le terrain pour le coup a dit qu'il
était absolument impensable de laisser
la situation comme ça et que pour le
moment l'Ukraine ne aucune stratégie
c'est la stratégie militaire
c'est-à-dire tout simplement récupérer
reconquérir ces territoires les
populations de ces territoires aussi qui
ne se considèrent pas forcément comme
prorose justement il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont
analysez-vous l'isolement russe par
rapport à la Chine par exemple qui ne
reconnaît pas cette annexion qui
condamne même hein les agressions
territoriales alors la Chine en fait
depuis le début en fait la Chine elle
est un peu sur une ligne de crête elle a
toujours condamné les atteintes à
l'intégrité territoriale et on comprend
bien pourquoi parce qu'elles se sont
directement concernées sociales
commencent à dire qu'on peut posséder un
bout un bout territoire tout son
discours autour de Taïwan tombe à l'eau
le cas de le dire donc bon mais là
disons qu'elle le redit depuis
effectivement 15 jours 3 semaines avec
un peu plus de force et elle dit il faut
une solution politique il faut une
négociation donc là elle le redit mais
faut quand même rappeler que ça ça a
toujours été sa position il y a l'Inde
aussi qui le Premier ministre indien qui
est qui a diable Vladimir c'est vraiment
pas le moment de faire la guerre au
sommet qu'il y a eu lieu récemment en
Ouzbékistan donc c'est des alliés
effectivement alors est-ce qu'à un
moment la question en fait c'est est-ce
qu'à un moment ils peuvent lâcher
Poutine c'est plus compliqué que ça je
pense parce que il y a aussi un point
commun qui unit tous ces pays l'un c'est
un peu différent mais en tout cas la
Chine et la Russie c'est tout ce qui
peut nuire aux États-Unis va dans le bon
sens donc voilà les Chinois je pense
vont essayer autant qu'ils le peuvent de
rester dans cette espèce de un peu de
double jeu quand même vis-à-vis des
Russes et de l'Occident
de territoire que personne ne reconnaît
y compris ses alliés il peut il peut le
décréter après la question c'est que que
fait le monde par rapport à ça on va
dire mais c'est vrai qu'il se met quand
même dans une position assez assez il
risque d'être tout seul dans cette dans
ce dans cette situation et ça
honnêtement c'est plutôt cette isolement
moi qui m'inquiète parce qu'à partir du
moment où il peut plus discuter avec
personne ou même il y a pas même il peut
il a même pas les Chinois avec lui voilà
il peut recourir à des
mesures extrêmes l'autre sujet enlève le
réécouter dans un instant et il promet
lui de mettre un terme au chaos c'est
ainsi que Brahim raï sil le président
iranien décrivait hier l'action des
manifestants manières de justifier la
mort de dizaines d'entre eux dans la
répression à l'heure actuellement en
Iran écouter en tout cas ce discours
c'était hier
la sécurité des personnes
voilà la ligne rouge de la République
islamique d'Iran
et personne n'est autorisé à enfreindre
la loi il y a semé le chaos
c'est inacceptable
Marsa mini.voile mal porté avait suscité
ce sont ces termes peines et chagrin
chez les Iraniens les autorités dit-il
présenteront bientôt un rapport final
sur ce décès il le promet c'est
suffisant pour calmer la fronde d'après
vous à Madame non bien sûr que non
puisque évidemment là on a dépassé très
très largement l'affaire tragique de la
pauvre Massa Amini il y a eu des
dizaines de morts il y a eu des
centaines d'arrestations c'est difficile
évidemment de savoir exactement ce qui
se passe mais quand même on arrive à
avoir enfin de contact régulier bien
qu'Internet soit coupé mais
régulièrement quand même les on arrive
en tout cas à voir quelques quelques
outres les vidéos qui sont sur les
réseaux sociaux mais en tout cas moi
j'arrive des fois avoir des contacts
avec des gens en Iran qui qui précisent
qui confirment que des choses se passent
après l'ampleur c'est toujours difficile
parce que chaque personne est tendance à
ville dans son dans son dans sa
situation ne s'est pas exactement ce qui
se passe ce qui est sûr c'est que il
continue à se passer des choses là ça
c'est un petit peu se calmer mais ça va
reprendre c'est vendredi c'est
traditionnellement là où il peut y avoir
des manifestations plus importantes une
grève générale peut-être voilà ce n'est
pas terminé après ce qui est sûr c'est
que voilà et vraiment ici c'est loin
d'être un enfant de cœur c'est loin
d'être quelqu'un avec qui on peut
discuter lui ou le numéro 1 du régime
qui est amené donc
c'est sûr que la méthode iranienne c'est
la répression et que ça va pas s'arrêter
non plus donc voilà qu'est-ce que à
partir de là ça devient complexe Lilian
qui n'hésite pas même à frapper le
Kurdistan irakien Bruno
oui alors là ils ont effectivement
frappé ils ont une des voilà des des
missiles contre selon Téhéran
effectivement des opposants iraniens
Kurdes Iraniens qui sont donc réfugiés
au Kurdistan irakiens alors c'est vrai
que le Kurdistan irakien accueille
depuis des années déjà des opposants
iraniens Kurdes et que
le début de l'affront des en Iran a
commencé dans la partie kurde de l'Iran
donc pour les autorités religieuses de
Téhéran c'est Kurdes sont des empêcheurs
de tourner en rond donc là ils les ont
ils les ont visés alors effectivement le
problème c'est que du coup ils ont
touché un état un état voisin mais enfin
qui est qui est officiellement
indépendant sauf que ils savaient très
bien que le Kurdistan irakien à
l'intérieur de l'Irak est quasiment un
État autonome et que donc il n'attendait
pas des des commentaires très outragés
d'ailleurs que je n'ai pas vu par
ailleurs de la part de bag d'autant plus
qu'à Bagdad la moitié de la classe
politique chiite est acquise à l'Iran il
y a une autre moitié chiite qui s'oppose
à l'influence de l'Iran mais enfin de ce
point de vue là pour parler de manière
impossynique et je pense qu'ils se
sentait un peu un peu tranquille mais il
n'empêche que ils ont frappé comme ça
une province d'un pays étranger avec le
risque peut-être d'un affrontement avec
les États-Unis parce que des forces
américaines un dépouillées dans le cadre
de la lutte anti djihadistes sont
présentes le sendcom et ils l'ont dit
ils ont abattu un drone iranien qui se
dirigeait vers la capitale du Kurdistan
irakien arbitre
sont très présents dans le curdistan R15
ce sont les alliés les alliés naturels
des cures de depuis très depuis toujours
donc mais bon pour le Kurdistan irakien
c'est d'ailleurs le même débat qui a eu
longtemps avec la Turquie puisque la
Turquie elle aussi faisait des
incursions dans le territoire
cure-directs en disant je vais
poursuivre des Kurdes turques mais bon
pour les Kurdes ce sont tous des Kurdes
donc à partir de là
la question est réglée donc c'est sûr
que c'est ça crée aussi les conditions
d'une potentiellement
rien à faire mais un peu d'accord avec
lui
mais c'est sûr que les Iraniens par
contre on sait ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il
y a eu une la composante entre
guillemets cure de la faire un peu été
mise de côté depuis le départ mais c'est
vrai que la population
jeune femme est originaire du Kurdistan
iranien le les Kurdes depuis toujours
conteste la République islamique il y a
un mouvement d'opposition cure très
important puisque la République
islamique ne reconnaît pas aussi la
culture kurde etc donc le fait que ça
s'embrasse aussi et il y a beaucoup de
minorités en Iran c'est un pays composé
en fait de multiples minorités donc si
jamais aussi il y a ce versant un peu
politique minorité qui s'embrasse ça
peut aussi jouer dans le fait que la
consultation conséquent très rapidement
à Berlin réclame des sanctions de
l'Union européenne contre l'Iran on peut
dire que le Jesse Pio et l'accord du son
nucléaire est définitivement mort alors
sauf peut-être pas aller trop vite quand
même il est en mauvais état
après c'est un peu un jeu moi je trouve
que c'est un peu un jeu de dupe c'est
peut-être un peu fort comme expression
mais entre les États-Unis qui savent
très bien ce qu'il voudrait et qui
disent des choses et qui pensent un peu
autrement et les Iraniens en fait qui
depuis des années joue de enfin
instrumentalisent un peu cet accord pour
rester sur une ligne de crête entre la
défiance le dialogue un coup la défiance
un coup le dialogue donc je pense pas
qu'ils aient intérêt à se priver de
cette en fait c'est un outil pour les
autorités iraniennes
parce que la dernière fois que ça
s'était calmé entre guillemets c'était
parce que les Iraniens espérer qu'avec
moins de sanctions économiques ça irait
mieux mais là je pense que même s'il y a
pas des sanctions économiques mais enfin
voilà là de toute façon il y a un
mouvement qui sera peut-être réprimé qui
s'arrêtera peut-être par répression mais
quelque chose dans la tectonique des
plaques merci Madame mustaphavi merci à
Bruno Darroux c'était ton va plus loin